catch up to light what might be called
the usual standards of the zone needs to
take part in discussions and add to
these discussions and free itself of
some of the hyper patriotism of the
early 90s and the cliches of the past
and their many cliches in that writing
and with that new creativity may come
and there are quite a number of young
historians who work in this field we are
going to be having said he leav Cola
from Cheney who is giving a talk here on
on Monday on Muslim Christian
Borderlands and looking at Ukraine as a
Muslim Christian borderland these are
the kind of new topics for the field
that also then can be generally
enriching for both polish historical
studies studies of the Commonwealth and
general European history thank you
issue the other
so the purpose of this is and yes
actually I use sets on this handle is
that HD about 10 in Chester you see the
author of the stable most notable was
dr. lynskey so why was she criticized I
was criticized now because you did not
get home developments okay the road
interstate people yeah she was
criticized largely on arguments that
there were problems intertextual use use
of sources mistakes in some citations
lose a huge review by two young scholar
Douglas and Rolla in shetland aesthetics
and then all of them have very clever
clever names nehru shiru see another
such thing then she answers then they
answer this one on didn't shed a lot for
a while now what was of significance in
this was that they never engaged her
actual topic but instead derided the
possibility of there being such a chef
thomas is with other major attack on her
but it was in this and this was allowed
to go out in a way that lets say the
tone was not that that you would usually
expect in a store
I i spoke with residue on chat about
this at that point in and said look and
brazil puppet both very distinguished
scholars in the field and said well
didn't anyone say to them take this back
and rewrite in some sort of normal
target i said and he's the reason
subconsciously because of the Prophet
you let this or didn't think or what
lake or said no no just didn't want to
interfere in this what I find of
interest is that this almost married the
topic that is her book may have failings
and maybe argue but the topic itself
wasn't Ellison and of course what you
really have been doing was bringing some
of the thought of Lipinski and others
into into polishes choreography and it
didn't take interesting it because of
that the date on that work yes sure gud
Ecco so yes it does no job and you have
mentioned about this question of the
political identity and ethnic identity
among them I find for example studies
locoroco skier who refers to himself as
a rock soul on him and I have a question
about that now he was a student of
Martin Luther as you well know and that
he wrote about the natural rights of man
the question is did he have any impact
he wrote in the ls 850 43 years later
did you have any impact on the political
and intellectual development in any
fashion because I thought well I know
what he did but I wonder what